les téléspectateurs vont voir revenir
les soeurs lilloise pauline et aurélie
que l'on avait connue en saison 3 le
couple cécilia matthieu de la saison 5
ou encore alizés et maxime de la saison
on retrouvera également les frères
bûcheron thomas et mathieu de la saison
12 et fabrice qui formait un duo
d'inconnus avec briac retrouvera une
grid qui formait un duo d'inconnus avec
nicolas en saison 7
le principe du jeu restera le même
plusieurs étapes 1 euro par jour et à la
clé un joli chèque de 100 mille euros
hélas trop 20e saison c'est la quinzième
saison pour le 15e anniversaire ce sera
une saison commencée parce qu'il va y
avoir une autre saison qui va partir en
tournage car dans quelques semaines à
peine là donc ça ce sont les candidats
les plus marquants et il ya un coin il
ya des candidats un duo que vraiment
très drôle ils étaient en couple en
saison 1 est la seule adresse dont
l'essai était bien divorcer mais ils
sont remis avec c'est finalement
l'arrivée des gens très bien alors
c'était michel était un succès sur m6
elle a disparu les revenus mais
j'aimerais que ça rame un peu comme le
retour non ça rame un peu mais aussi la
saison dernière qui est en moyenne à 2,2
millions téléspectateurs
les téléspectateurs reproché aussi à
l'émission d'être trop longue dans la
durée par épisode c'est un peu longuet
justement cette saison ce qu'ils ont
décidé de faire c'est d'accélérer de
dynamiser tout ça donc je pense que la
mayonnaise peut reprendre parce qu'on va
peut être revenir à des fondamentaux c
est ce qu ils ont reproduit des hommes
un peu un peu costaud parce que l'année
dernière c'était super jeu de chamboule
tous les abattoirs une kermesse tester
pas où l'ambiance faire mais là cette
saison il va y avoir du version all
stars avec des gens que les gens
connaissent déjà dont quelques uns des
staffs quoi la norme exactement mais je
lui dis souci sur le tournage
ils ont été interrompues en russie
n'avait pas les autorisations ils ont dû
repartir en france pour ensuite revenir
en russie
il n'avait pas les autorisations à dire
de prendre que des personnes